the starters arrived for the Donkey
Sanctuary but just when I thought it was
all going to plan Alex has forgotten to
serve the wine how do we put the
starters down without serving the
wine um of all tables come
on at 9:00 the restaurant's full but
bizarrely there's a backlog of people
waiting for
tables it's Alex's responsibility to get
them seated but he's flapping around
like a headless
chicken what's going on with this
[__] table that's waiting the bar for
so long table six Table Six yeah I
double booked at you see at the start of
the night and I had to tell them that
you know we need to have the table back
who did you tell you need the table back
the customer the customer what about the
[__]
kitchen they need to know first cuz they
got to cook it yeah so they move your
Assa for some bizarre reason Alex has
got tables double booked within an hour
no one can eat anything within an hour
embarrassing I mean [__]
embarrassing has simply got greedy in
thinking they can turn tables around in
an
hour as a result people are turning up
for the reservations but have nowhere to
sit and in the Kitchen Lawrence is now
struggling with a backlog of
orders the donkey table on top of all
that Alex has now gone into meltdown
Alex get a grip Alex you can do it
Alex you can [__] do it do we're wait
on you I know you're waiting on me and I
really appreciate this this is [__]
critical go come on Alex
please we waited for 40 minutes for
starter then sat with dirty plates for
45 minutes and then we were asked to
leave the table because the next lot of
um guests arrive five P here 1 2 3 4
five five
five although Under Pressure Lawrence is
at least coping with my reduced menu yep
you're three no three watermelon yet
finish those off in a minute soon as I
get these
out I can only be grateful that
Lawrence's got the Donkey Sanctuary main
courses out before the [__] hit the fan
very very nice I mean it was a lot nicer
than chicken banana I must admit the
food is actually very good um I think
everybody's quite pleased with the food
if he can come up with this sort of deal
yes we'll be back again but the service
Lees leaves quite a little bit to be
desired I think a lot more work on the
service believe me that
it's the end of the evening and
Lawrence's cooking has been a
success but Alex's double booking
madness has let everyone
down we're So Close
Alex so
close you can do better I know I can do
better you can do better I know I can do
better turn around and tell him that
he's paying your
salary
do we say our
pray I'm shaking like a leap
inside I don't know whether on this
planet next planet but I'm definitely on
a traditional Pub Planet he better be
the pub is packed out tonight but if
Brian and Elaine are going to start
paying off their huge debts this can't
be a
oneoff 60 minutes from the start of the
main course game two roast beef first
table
[Music]
St rapid though here we go and last
those
cobwebs for the first time ever they're
aiming to fill the dining room twice
over so they can't waste time pouring
wine or gravy for the customers
tonight Mr Foster yes you've got him on
table for l oh in this SP three sorry
did you wait long No 5 minutes perfect
gra you happy with great yor buing
sensation fantastic so far so good the
kitchen seems to be coping well under
pressure just be careful all these main
CES flying out now desserts next right
how many have we done I about 40ish
maybe about 45 just go up to 50 yeah
over halfway yeah keep it going
yes but out front there's a disaster
waiting to happen it's 8:30 and they're
slipping into Old Habits the bar is full
of people waiting to be seated Brian and
elae haven't got the first customers off
the tables
yet Brian we got a bit of a ke forming
yeah can we sit some guest down yes
we're just trying to get them to move
the tables to sit them down if they
don't move tell where's the
ri um I'll get somebody to bring the
bill for you thanks we've got to get
them out of these tables now you know
that's we got to be firm now yes
yep what you're finding harder to
transition it's not a restaurant it's a
pub y so don't be scared after 1 1 hour
55 minutes would you mind taking coffee
in the bar or come and have a drink in
the bar change those tables if you don't
do that in the next 15 minutes we're
going to be in the [__]
[__] have you got a bill for table that
one whichever one it
is it's been touch and go but at last
the second sitting at their tables
that's the hardest thing right now isn't
it got to turn it around and for the
first time ever it's starting to run
like a PB if we get through this one
tonight and he pulls it off you know
I'll be a lot happier of course I'll be
a lot happier my worri is in the kitchen
not with Tim but with Nick if he gets in
the [__] early on let's hope he's got
the Charisma the personality the drive
the determination to get out of it this
is not just a man starting off aresh
this is a man that is desperately in the
[__] up to his eyeballs with 100 Grand
of debt and [__] me every plate he cooks
he has to really seriously mean
it table in the
window
okay one crispy duck salad on order two
gaspacho chicken mackerel
[Music]
lamb nice absolutely
stunning good to sou late they're very
hot Lawrence please be careful
yes excellent start's gone within 7
Minutes
fantastic magaz is filling up with the
locals there'll be more people in
tonight than Nick would usually have in
all week how long you duct him where did
he win you up okay duck down yeah good
nice see play thank you that's fine
that's don't play with it don't play
with it despite the fact that we got rid
of Nick's fancy ingredients he's still
fiddling he can't afford to switch up
tonight what those little burn bits and
the potato there what are
they come on come on come on come on
Nick get Tim to put the peas and around
there and don't keep on sashing down so
much yet here calm down slow down guys
and work as a team like we sort of
almost in love with each other there you
go the new menu is doing the trick the
pace is picked up in the kitchen but
it's getting busy and now Nick has
taking his eye off the orders that guys
table two is already gone thank you what
you mean why's that ticket please temp
what is going
on thank you that's all I want what is
going on I don't know what's going this
never
happens Nick stop my man yeah we're
doing the same course again twice over
all right the next order is a chicken
and a
mael come on come on guys not tonight
I've all not tonight yeah I didn't I
didn't know you had a Lem on there I
thought it was a chicken and a
mackerel chicken and a mackerel
take take that one with
you Nick's just screwed himself they've
just started to cook one table's order
twice over brilliant it doesn't need to
be as panicky as it is Fu me this is
home cooking big deep breath and just
compose yourself yourself and be
comfortable doing three or four things
at the same time and bring it together
the r is now at his busiest so if Nick
doesn't take control now we're in
trouble our bollock is sinking Tim we
need two duck now move it come on
service please we got three Su plays out
yeah denying do two play three duck yeah
two Su play three
duck right we go seven chicken two lamb
yeah yes
sure and you got your sides on the go
yes H you got your side orders on the
go car finally for the first time this
week I'm beginning to see Nick might
just have what it takes to run his
restaurant 20 seconds 30 seconds placing
the chicken Tim are you ready with that
soup L nearly
Chef finished with the duck we through
the worst all the Ming he served and I
think Nick's even enjoyed
himself just there you know that Nick
just Laura has finished sulking and has
decided to lend a
hand Laura welcome back thank you
concerned about assistant manager
manager or just concerned about running
the place just concerned that the place
is running smoothly good I've still
expected him to Roar but for now hello
I'm quite happy I'm quite stable he
unsettles
[Laughter]
[Music]
me [__] big night tonight yeah could
be something quite major don't [__] it
when the [__] hits the fan we stay
United we've all got our jobs to do with
no
interference no interference I'm very
happy I'm very happy to take a back seat
the celebrities have taken the bait
first in are Hol Oak Stars Sarah dun and
Jennifer bidd
the footballer wives have come too
including Louise Owen Michael's wife and
next in is Sher Murphy where Wags hang
out others will surely follow my
strategy is paid off good to see you
hungry St yes going to eat dessert as
well yeah there no skinny minis here are
we got proper proper proper Foodies okay
who doesn't need to be behind the bar
there's no one on the floor there's five
people behind the bar Helen's cracking
the Whip and keeping sand and the
waitress is in
line the new menu's going down well can
I get the roast chck table seven fre
chicken but Phil has a problem Laura an
order be taken you took it on table six
and there's no check in the kitchen
nothing on the top there an order has
gone missing and the customers are
waiting been waiting 20 minutes can you
go and sort it out please did he get a
table six in well come on guys it was
the smoke salmon for me and chicken and
lamb start us out straight away please M
yeah it's not your fault yeah one had it
one salmon one chicken one lamb please
Phil yeah try and push that table
forward fck now and night like tonight
Joy thank [__] the kitchen solid that's
all I'm saying oh God two rotos yes yes
good man don't drop yeah no will'll Phil
keep his concentration and cook my menu
well enough to impress Walton's
glitterati this is two more [__]
nothing it's very to keep fing
conation despite the [__] up everyone
seems happy I just hope the customers
want to bid for s's
[Applause]
antiques Sandy may be clueless about
running restaurants but when it comes to
selling antiques she's a natural Mr Ron
what are we going to start at off house2
but somebody will me 20 20 is
30 any ADV on
5050 is one
[Music]
Chien 70 over there 8090 00 that's your
bid dirty Chef's a Happy Chef like a pig
in [__] let's go we have table 10 45
thank we're selling at £45 now I'll get
it I'll get it oh 50 just
5050 the local celebrities are flashing
their cash but what do they think of the
food it's very
nice it's delicious actually cuz it's a
bit crispy but it's also very tender as
well it's lovely really really nice I'm
really impressed I definitely come back
again it's been somewhere that I've
never actually come along to cuz I've
heard good and bad things about it but
um yeah definitely come back Phil's
cooked his heart out and not burnt a
thing a few more in Sal
as he says as he just [__] knock the
salsa over [__] H what a
SW